[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to with far from home making its
way around the world in more ways than
one it's time to break down one of the
movie's biggest talking points which
comes in the form of Mysterio the
enigmatic hero that is lining up to
replace Iron Man as Earth's greatest
protector throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about Mysterio as well as how
the movie took inspiration from the
comics there will be heavy spoilers so
if you haven't seen far from home yet
and don't want to know anything about
the character then I highly recommend
that you turn off now with that out the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for clicking this video I hope you enjoy
it now sit back relax and let's get into
my breakdown of Mysterio and far from
home Mysterio aka Quentin Beck is
apparently from Earth 833 a planet that
was supposedly ravaged by the elementals
tying back to the source material earth
833 and the comics doesn't actually have
the spider-man that we know as Peter
Parker was never bitten by a radioactive
spider and therefore the character never
came to be instead on that earth it was
in fact a William Braddock who was
bitten and he took on the pseudonym
spider UK spider UK is able to jump from
dimension to dimension however when he
went to return to his earth he found it
destroyed in a cosmic event it known as
the incursion so it looks like
everything lines up now we know why
Mysterio doesn't know who spider-man is
why his world was destroyed and I guess
we should just hand over the Edith
glasses and be happy that they're in
safe hands right well in far from home
even though his backstory is pretty
accurate to the comics we actually
discovered that Mysterio is in fact the
personification of a group of people who
all have serious vendetta's against Tony
Stark with Quentin Beck heading them up
Beck was the original creator of bath
which appeared in Captain America's
Civil War and whilst the technology was
revolutionary stock only used it for a
therapeutic experiment and then
mothballed it much to Beck's dismay in
addition to this many of the people that
now work with back have been scorned in
the past by stalks achievements
including a scientist from the original
Ironman that was berated by Obadiah
Stane but not being able to recreate the
arc reactor since Tony Stark sacrificed
himself to save the universe Beck has
viewed his death as an opportunity to
rise to the forefront and using his
incredible holographic technology
attached to drones he is able to
convince the world Jay jonah Jameson and
spider-man he is the planets greatest
hope this is all set up to obtain Edythe
the AI tool created by Tony Stark that
has a fleet of drones which are capable
of protecting the planet should another
Thanos level threat arrive upon his
death stalk intrested this power to
Peter however due to the doubt that Beck
casts in the wall crawl his head
throughout the film the character
decides to pass over the ownership of it
to Mysterio this enables Mysterio to
launch a full-scale attack on London
which will cement his spa's Earth's
Mightiest protector but luckily
spider-man is here to put an end to that
plan and after Mysterio recklessly uses
his drones to fire at the webhead he is
caught in the blast zone
now one of the biggest questions
floating around this ending is did
Mysterio die well personally I don't
believe that he did during the movie in
several scenes he's able to use
duplicates to make it appear as if he is
back is more than enough technology to
make it look like he's dying and also
access to Edythe which is the only thing
that verifies his death and no point did
he really have the proper opportunity to
film the segment that reveals that Peter
Parker is spider-man and after my second
watch of the film I'm convinced that
he's still out there somewhere
it's something I've kind of went back
and forth on and we won't know for
definite for a while but the entire plot
of far from home is about deception
which not only comes in the form of
Mysterio but also in Nick Fury and
Murray Hill anyway before I bogged this
video down in fan theories let's discuss
Mysterio's origins from the comics and
how they played into the movie Mysterio
originally debuted in the amazing
spider-man 13 from 1964 and was created
by Stan Lee and Steve Ditko though this
is know it as his first appearance he
was later credited as being responsible
for an alien invasion a Turner to be
hopes from issue 2 of the same run
Mysterio has been a member
the sinister six at several points
throughout his history and if he wants
to return I definitely think he would
fit in well with the Scorpion and the
vulture who were also scored by stop the
stereo hasn't just went after spider-man
either and in the story daredevil
guardian devil Mysterio believed that he
could find a more worthy arch enemy in
the hero and tormented him with visions
of the Antichrist this really hit home
for the character due to his Catholicism
and though Mysterio committed suicide at
the end of the run he was later brought
back to life down the line
old man Logan Mysterio managed to trick
Wolverine into murdering world the x-men
and this became a huge plot point for
the story that pretty much drove the man
formerly known as Weapon X to put away
his cause for good it's clear that
whilst he may look pretty goofy he's
actually one of spider-man's greatest
foes and I definitely think that this
transfers to the screen amazingly in
Gyllenhaal's performance in the comics
Mysterio is a former special effects
artist turned bad and the new film
beautifully weaves this into the prior
MCU films through the Civil War callback
all in all it makes for a great villain
and he's definitely one of the stronger
foes in the MCU at this point having
beautifully brought down spider-man by
the film's clothes obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on Mysterio and if
you enjoy the portrayal of him and far
from home or not comment below and I
just want to let you know that we're
giving away a free copy of Avengers
endgame to one lucky winner and all you
have to do is like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the movie in the
comments below the winner will be chosen
at random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from there
to whoever gets the prize best of luck
to everyone who takes part and if you
love this video 3000 then please give it
a thumbs up and if you want to know more
about far from home and where I think
the movies could go in the future after
the big post-credit scene and make sure
you check out my ending explained
breakdown which would be linked at the
end it covers all of the potential
futures of phase 4 and is definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more I'll leave that linked at the end
and hopefully I'll see you over there
after this this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
that you've been the best and
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]